ja da Bedarf ist zunächst einmal einer
Debatte und die wollen wir führen mit
Ahmed Mansour er ist Psychologe und
extremismusexperte Hermann Suhr das
Innenministerium sagt es gebe noch keine
Übersicht über die Täter finden sie ist
trotzdem legitim das junge Migranten
jetzt als eine haupttätergruppe benannt
werden
absolut vor allem weil ich diese
Erfahrungen auch an dem Abend gemacht
habe weil ich viel mit Polizeibeamter
und Rettungskräfte gesprochen habe und
weil es nicht zum ersten Mal gekommen
ist wir haben schon Zahlen von
denjenigen die schon in Haft waren und
gerade wieder auf freien Fuß sind und
das zeigt dass die Menschen mit
Migrationshintergrund oberproportional
vertreten sind es geht nicht darum jetzt
alle Menschen mit Migrationshintergrund
dafür verantwortlich zu machen aber da
wo Sozialisation eine Rolle spielt muss
das in aller Deutlichkeit auch gesagt
werden
sie haben zu den Ursachen geforscht
können Sie uns vielleicht einige nennen
erstmal mussten wir diese Ereignisse
nicht punktuell wahrnehmen wir haben
schon immer wieder solche Ereignisse
gehabt wenn wir europaweit anschauen
dann sollten wir bitte nach Paris nach
Brüssel nach Stuttgart nach Frankfurt
nach Berlin im Sommer sehen und da sehen
wir schon ein Muster der sich wiederholt
von Menschen mit Migrationshintergrund
die einfach unser Rechtsstaat nicht
akzeptieren die eine gewisse Verachtung
gegenüber Gesetze und Vertreter diese
Staate zeigen und das kommt immer wieder
zum Ausdruck und das hat mit
materialische Strukturen das hat mit
Sozialisation mit Erziehungsmethoden zu
tun und darüber muss man in aller
Deutlichkeit reden nicht um diese
Menschen jetzt allgemeiner als Risiko zu
sehen sondern vor allem um zu schauen
wie können wir diese Menschen am besten
erreichen bevor sie zu Straftaten
greifen wie festgezogen sind denn diese
Strukturen von denen sie sprechen kann
man da überhaupt noch drauf einwirken
ich mache die Erfahrung nicht arbeite ja
viel im Gefängnissen aber auch in
Schulen und ich mache die Erfahrungen
man kann viele Menschen gewinnen noch
bevor sie sozusagen zum Straftaten
greifen das heißt Präventionsarbeit das
heißt gewinnend arbeiten das heißt alles
zu tun um unsere Gesellschaft
vorzustellen um Begegnungen zu schaffen
um diese Menschen vor Freiheit und
Demokratie zu gewinnen wenn sie aber
schon im Gefängnis sitzen wenn sie schon
Straftaten begangen haben und zwar
Konsequenz immer wieder dann ist es
natürlich sehr sehr schwer diese
Menschen zu erreichen da helfen
natürlich vor allem
starker und harter Konsequenzen die wir
brauchen und Botschaften zu vermitteln
an all diejenigen die vielleicht auch
mit diese Idee fantasieren in der
Zukunft Polizeibeamter anzugreifen
Polizeibeamte anzugreifen ist kein
bagatellit ist ist ein Tabubruch die er
begangen wird und darauf müssen wir
reagieren das heißt ich höre verstehe
sie richtig eine Strafe Schärfung wie
sie ja auch diskutiert wird im Moment
für solche Taten würden sie befürworten
ich sehe drei eigentlich drei Themen die
wir auf jeden Fall tun müssen erstmal
müssen wir diese Debatte offen führen
und wir müssen auch die Ursachen
benennen zweitens wir brauchen härtere
Strafen damit wir auch Botschaften
vermitteln dass das nicht geht aber wir
brauchen auch
Präventionsarbeit Integrationsarbeit um
die Menschen zu gewinnen bevor es dazu
tun dazu kommt mein Problem ist mit
dieser einseitiger Betrachtung und
einseitiger Lösungs die da angeboten
werden vor allem von Politiker die meine
Meinung nach sehr pauschal und sehr
unklar formuliert sind und da brauchen
wir einfach eine viel wichtiger
lösungsorientierter Konzepte um Berlin
sozusagen auch nächstes Jahr von solchen
Daten zu befreien können Sie da mal so
ein Lösungskonzept sagen was sind das
weil man ja auch von gescheiterter
Integrationspolitik spricht wie kann man
das besser machen in Zukunft
also erstmal haben wir mit vielen
Menschen zu tun übrigens auch mit Flucht
Erfahrungen die aus patriarchalischen
Strukturen kommen aus Staaten die sehr
autoritär auftreten und beim begegnen
mit den deutschen Staaten mit der
Polizei mit dem Justiz haben viele diese
Menschen das Gefühl dass der Staat sehr
schwach ist und dass die Polizei sehr
schwach ist es entsteht ein Feindbild
Polizei ein Feindbild Staat eine
Verachtung gegenüber die Werte und ich
glaube wir tun uns
ein gefahren wenn wir anfangen Werte zu
vermitteln wenn wir versuchen
Begegnungen auch mit Polizeibeamter im
Alltag zu schaffen und wenn wir diese
Menschen vor Freiheit und Demokratie
gewinnen sie sind ja deshalb in
Deutschland weil sie Freiheit und
Sicherheit suchen und deshalb müssen wir
das attraktiver gestalten vermitteln und
dadurch diese Menschen einfach erklären
warum der Staat so reagiert wie viele
reagiert und die Erfahrung die ich mache
zeigen es funktioniert wenn man auf
Augenhöhe diese Drucke auch mit den
Menschen führt ach mit meinen Sohn zu
einer Debatte die vielleicht gerade erst
begonnen hat ganz herzlichen Dank gerne